- So that was a look at her show, "1883."
You can see it on Paramount+.
So this show, "1883,"
it's your first major acting role?
'Cause I know that you
were in "Stepford Wives."
- Yes.
- And you've been
in some things, yeah.
I loved that one.
So, was it something that
you've always wanted to do
and you dipped your toes in a little bit,
but then you had decided to just jump in?
- Yes, I started singing in church.
- Yeah.
- But the first thing
that I did when I was in lower school,
middle school, high school, were plays.
I was on stage all the time.
- Yeah.
- But then my career took off,
no time, had babies.
- Yeah.
- Kept on having babies.
Felt like I was having
babies all the time.
- Yeah.
- And I had done
a couple of things.
- Yeah.
- I did "Stepford Wives"
with an amazing cast.
- Amazing, yeah?
- An amazing cast.
It wasn't the best experience.
So I said, "I will never, ever, ever,
"ever do another, anything--"
- Was it not--
- "Like that, a movie,"
because it took so long.
The waiting for me,
you have to understand.
- Hurry up and wait.
- I cannot, I have to be busy doing stuff.
- Yeah.
- Anyway, and then I did
an independent thing called "Dixie Land,"
but I've read a lot of
scripts over the years
and this--
- Nothing ever really hit ya?
- Nothing hit me or the
timing wasn't right,
and then for the script to have been
so incredibly well-written,
I honestly had never
read anything like it.
We're talking about "1883."
- Yeah.
- And so we just made
the decision to do it, to do it.